when choosing a premium laptop you've
generally got a choice between a windows
machine and a macbook
with windows laptops usually offering
more performance and features
at a lower price point and that's the
case for huawei's matebook x pro
with the quad core processor 16
gigabytes of ram
a 3k touchscreen display 512 gigabytes
of nvme ssd storage
full speed thunderbolt 3 and a dedicated
graphics chip
you truly get a lot for your 1500 and
it's constantly on sale for
just thirteen hundred dollars and that's
why we're comparing it to apple's
thirteen hundred dollar
2017 13-inch macbook pro which is
constantly on sale for around twelve
hundred dollars
we've got links to those sales in the
video description below so we're going
to be comparing everything we can
between these laptops
but we'll focus on things that affect
your day-to-day experience
like the display keyboard trackpad
speakers and overall usability by far
the biggest thing that affects your
experience is the operating system
and if you like using windows 10 the
matebook x pro is the obvious choice for
what you get for the money
but there's a big market of people who
prefer mac os for reasons like better
reliability and higher resale value
and they're okay paying extra cash to
get it now for those who could really go
either way
let's compare both laptops and see which
laptop is better in each category
starting with exterior design the
matebook is slightly thicker near the
rear
but longer and thinner near the front
they both share a premium aluminum
design which was introduced by apple
many years ago
and the undersides look extremely
similar with cooling vents located away
from the bottom
so you can use it on your lap without
worrying about overheating
upon opening both laptops the matebook
almost looks like an exact copy of the
macbook
the truth is that it sucks for apple but
it's great for us consumers because the
design
is admittedly great with both laptops
looking so similar in design
it's gonna have to come down to the fine
details for the macbook to have a chance
of getting ahead
let's start with the displays from first
glance the matebooks display looks many
times better than the macbooks
the bezels are much thinner especially
at the top thanks to the relocation of
the webcam
literally built into a pop-up key on the
keyboard the resolution is higher
at 3k instead of 2.5 k and what i really
like about it is the very tall 3x2
aspect ratio
which is even taller than the macbook
macbook's 16x10 ratio
which gives you a lot more vertical
screen space compared to standard 16x9
which matters a lot for browsing the web
not only that but it's very color
accurate as well
with a 100 srgb coverage but the macbook
pro takes it further with dci p3 wide
color gamut
which covers 25 percent more color space
than srgb
the matebook also seems to lack contrast
with blacks looking a little bit gray
compared to deep blacks on the macbook
both displays are almost identical in
terms of maximum brightness
but the matebooks display is also a
touchscreen which can be nice to have
but we noticed that it's a bit more
reflective than the macbook pro
which can get a bit annoying in bright
conditions however i still think the
mate book wins out in the display
category for the near bezel-less design
and i think it was really clever to hide
the webcam to be able to achieve it
even though it makes for an unattractive
up the nose camera angle
i personally never use my macbook's
webcam anyway now let's get to the
keyboards
what you've heard about the macbook keys
is true they don't offer very much key
travel at
all the matebooks keys remind me of how
macbooks used to be
with substantially more key travel it
honestly just feels better to type on
the matebook
and you don't have to worry about the
dead key problem that macbooks have been
having which i personally haven't
experienced yet on any of the new
macbooks i've used
so i think it's a pretty rare problem
the matebook's power button doubles as a
fingerprint reader
which this model of the macbook pro
lacks to get touch id
you'll need to opt for the more
expensive touch bar model or a 2018
macbook air
before we test the speakers let's
compare the track pads
they look really similar with the
macbooks being slightly bigger
but apple uses force touch technology
which basically utilizes a motor beneath
the trackpad to simulate a click
click pressure is fully customizable and
you can press firmly after clicking once
to perform
additional options just like 3d touch on
recent iphones
the beauty of using this technology is
that you get an even clicking feel
all around the trackpad unlike the
matebooks trackpad
which is easy to click near the bottom
and almost unclickable near the top
the matebooks trackpad is still better
than most windows laptops out there
but the macbook pro easily wins in this
category now let's compare the speakers
starting with the sound comparison
[Applause]
[Music]
the few things i noticed is that the
highs were a lot better on the macbook
making it louder overall compared to the
matebook there wasn't much of a
difference in mids or bass
but the macbook sounds much more clear
compared to the mate book which sounds a
bit flat like various sound frequencies
are clashing together
so in almost every scenario the macbook
pro speaker sounded better
now let's quickly mention the ports both
get two usbc
ports with both of them on the macbook
pro supporting thunderbolt 3
and just one of them on the mate book
which also gets a usb a port which is
really convenient for using flash drives
and that port is missing on the macbook
with that said all that's left to
compare is specs and performance
you simply get so much more for your
money with the matebook a 4
core processor instead of a 2 core 16
gigabytes of ram compared to 8
512 gigabytes of ssd storage compared to
only 128 on the base macbook pro
so we recommend macbook users to get at
least 256 gigs
which brings the price up to 1500 and if
you're paying that much already
you may as well just pay 300 more for
the 2018 touch bar model instead
now the biggest difference is that the
matebook actually gets dedicated
graphics
which you can't get on the macbook pro
unless you opt for the 15 inch model
which starts at 2400 this was really
surprising to us and it puts the
matebook a step ahead
comparing geekbench 4 graphic scores the
difference in graphics performance is
significant
the quad core processor also destroys
the dual core on the macbook pro
especially in the real world cinebench
r15 cpu test
so what's the rundown which laptop is
the better choice
well if you don't mind using windows the
matebook x pro
is by far the better machine for your
money there are ways the macbook pro is
definitely better
but it's not nearly enough to top the
value of the matebook
and the best part is that it looks and
feels pretty similar to the macbook
with a much better display and keyboard
now if you own an iphone
apple watch maybe an ipad or a set of
earpods
you're gonna have a much better
experience with the macbook pro with all
the features you get with the apple
ecosystem
and macbooks generally tend to be more
reliable and age better compared to
windows laptops
so there's another factor to consider if
you plan on keeping your laptop for many
years but for the sake
of comparing the value of these two
laptops the matebook wins
if you enjoyed this comparison make sure
to hit that subscribe button above
because we're getting our hands on the
2019 imac really soon
and we'll be doing comparison videos on
that as well thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video